Any value greater than or equal to negative 2 3rds, but less than or equal to 1
half would be correct. Fantastic algebra work for getting this one correct. We
start solving this inequality by rewriting it as an equation. We factor this
expression to get 3x plus 2 times 2x minus 1. Now we're ready to set each of
these factors equal to 0 and solve for our values of x. Here, the 0s are the
values that make this equation equal 0, our x equals negative 2 3rds and x
equals 1 half. We use the values of x that make this statement equal to 0,
instead of three intervals on our number line. Next, we want to test each
interval and we'll start here. We'll let x equal negative 1 to get the
statement 3 is less than or equal to 0. We know this isn't true, so our first
interval is out. If we try a value between negative 2 3rds and 1 half, like 0,
we wind up with a true statement. This means any number in this region will be
a part of our solution. Finally, we test a number in the interval III, like 1,
to get a false statement. We know this isn't true, so this interval is out of
our solution set as well. We can use brackets at negative 2 3rds and positive 1
half, since we can be equal to 0. So these numbers on the number line would
work for our inequality and this would be the set in interval notation.